Nói tình khá tĩnh, công gân, định công hán tỏng. Ngay em chỉ tả mời là hai ngàn công chăm hai miter, công hán hệ
lý sôn, hà tĩnh đã hoàn tất hồ sơ và đen nghiệp truy tổ có công hán, sinh ngồi gình
chỉ chăm chỉ mê làm chú tệ cà lập, vę tổ chậm cấp tài sản theo đếp a, khẩn ba, e một chăm
bệ tì bà bộ lột thình dự, vô v liv sài ra châu tối ngày May 3, nhanh hán công chăm hai miter,
khi ra định bà chẳn tĩ hơn, lý sôn phát hiện mất hơn một chăm chậm đồng và vang
chỉ giả ba mê chậm đồng trong tụi đối phòng vô. Công hán nghe sôn đã nhên trong nhiều chá hiện chương,
khiến vùng đối tự, nhận định vụ án có thủ đạc tình vì lấy đạo công hán hệ đánh sát lập truyền án,
án sụ nhiều biệt pháp nghiệp vụ để tìm ra tụ pháp qua điều tra, có công hán được sách liệt là người thực hiện
hành vi chỗ cấp, tài tất cả quan điều tra, lưỡi trưởng vóa công hán đã cuy đợi khai dẫn hành vi phạp tổ của mình.
Mình mong bao tháng bệnh May 9, 2020, các quan cạnh sát đều tra công hán hệ lý sôn đã xa
tình có kênh án sau khi mắn hạn tụi vẫn tiếp tục chục khác, từ tăng mộp đến thặc tư nơi mai ngàn
cũng trong 20 tư với tụ đạc lúc nhập và cạnh phá kết sát, án thực hiện thêm so quốc trục tại
ghi xuân, tân lập, hà tính, và dính cho người an, chính bệnh tài sản chỉ giá gần muốn chăm trở đầu
để tiêu xa cái nhân và trời game.